[Music]
myself
in the new documentary havana libre
filmmaker corey mclean follows a
community of cuban surfers who refuse to
abandon their sport despite police
harassment government bureaucracy and
being shut off from the international
surfer community if you want to feel
something and understand cuba you just
need to get to know these characters
going about their lives trying to pursue
something that they love and seeing how
difficult it is
cuba has had this really difficult
relationship with the water
the cuban government essentially made
the water off limits to all of its
people
unless expressly given permission for
to try and develop a sport in that space
is already really difficult the fact
that it's primarily a western sport is
also not
particularly appealing to the government
there
and so together
those reasons basically forced surfing
to be this underground sort of invisible
sport and so a lot of what our film is
about is them no longer wanting to be
invisible wanting to be legitimate and
and be able to practice it in public
proudly
we would constantly be talking to the
surfers and they'd be like oh yeah you
know we got arrested there this time but
we had to run from the cops this time
like so it's illegal they'd be like
it's not legal and we'd be like so it's
illegal like
it's not legal
everything is nuanced there nothing is
straightforward
you may be fine you may come under
scrutiny you may get the full hammer of
the law and you just never really know
the subjects in havana libre are
distinctly anti-political and routinely
voice their desire to be free to
practice and enjoy their sport when i
asked frank
like how he identifies himself he
identifies himself as a surfer
it's not that they don't care about
politics or they don't care about what's
happening in their country it's it's
quite the opposite
but
for them that's the community that they
feel the most a part of is surfing it's
what they want to be the most a part of
and i think they really feel the
impediment of
these forces that are outside their
control kind of keeping them from what
they feel is basically their destiny
[Music]
it
one of the biggest obstacles cuban
surfers face is the american trade
embargo
you know it cuts off the ability for
them to get supplies to make boards and
knowledge everything
[Music]
surfing
what is that
everyone started surfing on plywood and
so frank one of our main characters
took the surface off of his school desk
when the teacher wasn't looking
basically like disassembled it ran out
the door and took it home and turned it
into a surfboard
and when they saw these magazine
clippings
it was this process of dissection and
mimicry they'd like get an image and
they'd be like oh it's not flat it's got
a little bit of a curve here like how
are we gonna get that curve and then
they'd see like
a picture of a broken board and be like
oh my god it's full of foam
the the common way that they started
making boards is they found
refrigerators and would strip the core
out of the door glue them together and
then use cheese graters to basically
sand it all down into shape sometimes it
could take like two years from start to
finish to make a surfboard
it just really hit us the whole process
of trying to connect there is so
challenging you know the internet thing
is tremendous
to get online costs three dollars and
the monthly cuban salary is only 20. the
fact that people are still doing it
tells you how important
that little piece of the puzzle is
maclean and his crew followed the
subjects on a trip to the us which had a
profound impact on everyone involved we
took them to all these places
kind of like trying to blow their minds
we're like
what do you think of this what do you
think of that
the place that blew their mind the most
was the grocery store
which to us was was heartbreaking
it was sort of this moment where
we realized that
they don't necessarily even know what
they're not a part of but they know that
there's something out there that
interests them that they want to be a
part of
and they don't necessarily have the full
scope of it yet and to see it in person
and to see the ease in which people are
able to pursue some of the things that
they can
um
yeah i think it's
i don't know both both heartbreaking and
heartwarming at the same time
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
there are a lot of films about cubans
leaving cuba
and i think what's different is that
our characters
still feel like cuba's home and they
want to be able to do it do what they
want to do at home
you see how much chaos
politics can cause in in day-to-day life
you know everything is connected to
politics and so for them surfing
is really this
ability to just
release all of that
and so when they say they're constantly
trying to escape politics
all they want to do is live in this
peaceful lifestyle that they see people
around the world being a part of
this film is sort of about how
difficult that simple task is
[Music]
you